S
MORNING ABOUTHUMP
ADMINITI
"NIGHTMARE SCENARIO" HOW
PRESIDENT TRUMP SUGGESTE
ND COVID-19
TO GUANTANAMO BA
THE U.
SUSPECTS.
JOING ME NOW
NATIONAL HEALTH REPO
ANESIDENT TRUMD CO  YOU T  EARL
TO GITMOISR REAL?
>> WELL,AL
AND HAVING READ IT COVER TO
COVEI CAN TELL YOU THE
LOTS OF VE THAT IN
"NIGHTMARE
WHHA
VEA L AT TIMES TOO BREAT
>> H INTO
HOW PRESIDENUMP LED THE
PANDEMIC TIME.
>> WELL, THENTANAMO BAY
REVELATIONS  EAR 2020
IALS WE G WITHT WI INFECTED AME
THATHE EOURE
RUS AND
OFALO BRING THOSE
SICK AMERICANS HOME TO GET THEM.
WHAT "NIGHTMARE SCENARIO
REPORTS IS THAT PRIDUM REPEATE
FEMECAGOO
NAMO B.
SS ABOUT
NUMBERS OFASES HD S DOWN OE
BAR HIS REELONS AMAZING,E DID S
ACCOIN
ONE OTRPT ADHERE WCHA CONSISTENT
TE
HE SAYS, QUOTETEG IS
KILLING ME, TRUMP REPORTEDLY EX
CES MED IN A PHONE CALL TO
SECRETARY ALEX AZAR ON
18th YELLINGO LOUDLY THAO LOSE
TI O
WHAT IDIOT HAD F
GOVERNNT
MEAN JARED, AZARESPONDED?
CITING THE PRESIDENT
KUSHNER.AND SON-IN-LAW JARED
WHAT WAS THEON HERE?
>> WELL, TS IN THE ME
OF MARCHON HAD
STARTED SHOWN, THE HAD
EVENTJUST A FEW DAYS EARLIER WP
THE TALKGOOGLE HELPING TRACK
TESTS AND WHO MIT NEEDM
AND AS AULG DID
HOOTP,
EFFORTID
TESTS, THE NUMBERSTAED
UP, PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO HAD
THAT THE VIRUS WOUO AWAY
IMMINENTLY WAS NOW BEING PROVEN
FOOLISH AS THOSE ROSE,G TOAKOUTN
HEALTH SECRERY, BUINE WERE LOTS
INUD
SON-IN-LAW, WHO ORKING TO
MATING A REALITY.
>> YOU KNOW, THIS ILRA
E LARGER DREAMS K, AT
M THE
OF ,
WHICH IS THAT THERE WAS A
CONSISTESS
CHARGE.
WHO TUALLY MAKING THINGS HAPPE
WAS ITIKE  WAST
BIRX, WAS ITNG?
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE IT WATH
ENT OF
TALK TUSHIDEH A DETRIMENT.
>> I THINK WHAT ENDE
HAPPENING WAS PREST
TIMES CREDIT WHEUEHE BUREAUCRAC.
THOUGHT THE COULD BE DEVELOPED I
AND ANGER IT JUST BECAME AN
OBSTACLE TO WORK AROUND.
INSTANERGENCY PREPAREDNESS CHIE
AMM OVERSEASHETEE THE STATMENT A
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S MENT DEPUTIES
OBVIOUSLY PRESIDENT TRUMP WANTED
TO FIRE TONY FAUCI, TO
THATIDPPEN.
I ON A
G SHOW WHERE SOMEONE IS
ND BRIANNA
CONSTANTLY AND YOU'RTRO
R JOB.
THCH OF AT
THATGOE ABLE TBEWALLED OFF FROMY
TRYINGDO
NSTANTLY
EAALLENGES FOR HIS
TEAM INCLUDING WHOG
WAS IT MIKE PENCE AT RONAVIRUS ?
S  DEBORAH BIRTHDOCTOR ADVISING?
WAS ITAR WHO WAS R
CONSEQUENCES OF NO HE  CISIONS T
WILLING TO ME F THE
HARDEST CALLS.
GOHED
WHOES HE KNOW? I AM A REPORTT N
BA I'VE >> D DIAMOND APPRECIATE
READING AND Y